[Music]
I'll just say that so I have a
six-year-old daughter who has been given
me a really difficult time recently
about coming out to events in the
evening for work and today when I was
getting ready to come here she started
grilling me I'm trainee does work on
yeah what does he do work on inspection
stories and it's my pleasure to
introduce Andre we we've lived out
graduate school days together at NYU in
the American Studies Program Andres
research focuses on the cultural
politics of race gender and genre in
20th century black and American
literature and arts his first book
speculative blackness interrogate the
meanings of race and genre through
studies of science fiction fanzines
comics film and television and other
speculative fiction texts his current
research project audio futurism explores
literary adaptation and sound studies
through the analysis of science fiction
radio plays based on the work of black
authors and we're privileged to hear
some of that work today as its
development his writings have appeared
in the journals present tense sounding
out callaloo and African and black
diaspora and books including a companion
to the Harlem Renaissance the black are
the ink constructions of blackness and
comics
sequential art and black gay genius and
stream Joseph Eames call he has been
called on as a peer reviewer for the
Journal of homosexuality the James
Baldwin review and african-american
review and serves on the editorial
advisory board for the Journal of modern
literature in 2015 he organized the
first international peers and comics
conference through claddings the Center
for LGBTQ studies in New York in
addition to a primary literature he
teaches courses on comics and graphic
novels LGBTQ literature and culture
global black literature and literary um
I want to say thanks to be back for the
generous introduction and I want to say
thank you all for coming now
despite you know whatever travails
probably go through to get here or at
least like to get from where you were
yesterday today I want to thank Jessica
tuck the administrator who made most of
these things happen and Andrew Whitaker
or or officially extending the invite
and I want to thank a lot of people who
do the administrative work and keep the
building clean and safe and keep the
lights on and shove all the walks and
put too much salt on the sidewalk so
that we can I don't know their names but
if you do thank them so this is um this
is the tip of the iceberg
it's funny story it will make sense
momentarily I hope a few weeks ago in
conversation with a grad student at the
University of Pennsylvania I came up
with an extended metaphor or the tip of
the iceberg for capturing the
relationship between a phenomenon that
she had identified in some
african-american texts that are
otherwise realist and the broader
considerations around genre that we
call afro-futurist spurred on by the
interventions of critics like Richard I
mean quality of tape I've maintained a
sense that african-american cultural
production always has something
understated in relation to it a twin we
can learn from posing the question of
what african-american literature is and
we can also learn about what it is not
by doing that we can learn about what
being african-american literature is not
being the tradition itself represents
the kind of quasi national project that
can learn outlines as a response to the
Negro problem in what was African
American literature in order to argue
that contemporary black writing is not
doing that anymore it is being something
else
and that to me is exciting it means that
we can learn something new we can learn
what to do instead so if the leftovers
from that tradition than that to try to
us the undesirable and the improper
texts that trail along behind that
project are like ducklings in a row
behind the mother then they still belong
to the genus that Kevin Young called the
shadow book the unfinished the unwritten
The Lost ex I mean to use our time
together to illustrate how I'm setting
about the next stage in my research by
writing the shadow book to speculative
blackness the book that I didn't write
while it was being written instead and
the one that I will write now that its
counterpart is out there being itself
the extended metaphor that I came up
with to explain a seeming eruption of a
para literary within the literary for a
student re-examining conventional text
was the tip of the iceberg when I say
that you might picture a canine peak
exposing its Menace to the Dean Titanic
icebergs originally in the paradigm
matically slow movement of glaciers we
can imagine this heavy mysterious
geological object if it is
african-american literature as something
like a reliquary for black knowledge
when it meets the sea the mountain of
frozen and fresh water breaks apart
calves to send an aspect of itself out
into the chaos of intercourse with all
sorts of ocean currents cargo vessels
keister doors assemblies of cetaceans
other states of matter and energy moving
about much faster than its experienced
in a long time most of the action in the
iceberg we know takes place below the
surface where we can't see and it's
mostly silent when the very old very
dense ice splinters away from its source
at a point of contact with salt water
the interacting forces can cause the ice
break iceberg not just to break off but
to tip over exposing its erstwhile
underside
it's a view it's an exceptional sight
but it's coming more likely now because
of climate change the scientific
explanation for this process belongs to
physicist Justin Burton at Emory but its
aesthetic implications are what make it
fascinating to me our disciplinary
perspectives typically afford us caution
and insight that's appropriate to
observing rational and irrational
phenomena and telling them apart but
occasionally a dazzling spectacle like
this shakes us out of our confidence you
know we should know better we should
know it's nothing special looks like I
told Keanu that the moment she
identified in black writing could be the
tip of the iceberg in this more dramatic
way temporary unstable and rare but
fascinating
so discerning a minor tendency and
unremarkable pattern and cultural
politics that militates against shark
Zamora distinctions in the interest of
reappraising the versatility of certain
authors which is my own colleagues
ambition is a worthwhile endeavor
because it challenges us to rethink how
black writers enunciate their
relationship to speculation and to
mimesis as aesthetic objectives while
speculative fiction by black authors may
be the tip of the proverbial iceberg our
knowledge of the greater literary whole
is fundamentally altered by the sublime
vision of a world that was previously
submerged when the tip of the iceberg
isn't a fragmentary object that we see
but a whole event we learn more than we
could by examining what's normally
visible and usually silent we gain
insight into
formation of the glacier from which it
emerged physicists study glacial
movement including the improbable but
dangerous phenomenon wherein icebergs
tip over these events can generate
seismic forces and tantamount to
significant terrestrial earthquakes and
devastating waves that threaten life on
Islands and maritime trade I find the
spectacle of an overturned iceberg
compelling because it represents the
coexistence of something otherworldly in
appearance and behavior within a larger
seemingly inert totality to apply this
concept to my research agenda like a
glacier speculative blackness is more
than the sum of its constituent parts
since it's been in print I realized that
it's part of a larger inquiry into the
cultural politics of genre as they're
articulated in a range of media it has
at least one shadow book as yet
unrealized exploration of science
fiction embrace thinking that probably
turns its approach upside down in the
course of providing you with an account
of the work that will form the basis of
my second book project I'll tell you how
sound has worked as a silent partner of
my contributions to the scholarship of
blackness and speculative fiction so far
the critical itinerary of sound and
black study has been indelibly marked by
the influence of music which we can
erase ea in the interventions of Louis
XI de Seok a friend looking Carter
Mathis CC Xiao Jian Shana read well the
questions I addressed prior to my
engagement with sound studies set the
stage for my investigation in a slightly
different manner I have different work
to do in order to illustrate how this
next stage in my research represents the
divergence of an agenda that's already
differentiated from other forays into
the field I have to step back to the
Glacial scale at which this calving
takes place by comprehending a sudden
audible crack as part of a
centuries-long process I hope to explain
how the emergent aspect of my
scholarship that I'm calling audio
futurism relates to an inchoate totality
a vision of the larger field of cultural
production that we will have attained
once we articulate the relay
of its parts to the whole
[Music]
I use the future interior tents as a
gesture to an afro futurist treatment of
astrology authored by my neighbor's
philadelphia-based
iowa who performs if more mother goddess
and rashid a philips founder of the
afro-futurist affair more mothers works
as you can hear fuse metal rhythm and
blues jazz and vocal distortion with
titles like how to use ancient hip-hop
beats to see into the future past free
jazz for the free doom and the afterlife
of events the latter which he heard an
excerpt from was created as part of the
collaboration black quantum futurism
it's a howl for the late Sandra bland
the liner notes for the afterlife of
events read in part we applied the black
quantum futurism gaze to study the
afterlife of events and astrological
influences surrounding the birth arrest
and death of Sandra bland in order to
synchronize the influences playing a
role in black women genocide black
quantum futurism cites an obscure
British occultist Dennis Elwell to
deploy a theory of retroactive causality
one of the digital artifacts
accompanying their sound art includes a
set of natal charts for Sandra Bland's
birth for arrest and her death the
document proclaims we believe that
astrological events are reversed enact
retro causally from the cosmic future to
influence present events that will be
subsequently written on the fabric of
the past by light crafting horoscopes
for the dead makes sense when
irreversible events are understood as
part of a process in which the present
is being drawn toward its future state
in this unusual rendering future moments
affect the event of causes in their past
they look like horoscopes and
they sound like that black quantum
futurism and more mother of represent a
long legacy of avant-garde
experimentation in black music and sound
culture there's no esthetic more iconic
in this realm than that of the jazz band
leader son Rob sunrise should have been
mentioned the term after a few
but he didn't the prehistory of the word
invoked by the terms originator mark
Derry positions son Ron conversation
with Jimi Hendrix b-boy performance
artists were Mel Z internal scholars
from Fred Milton to Eric Stein's Co
highlight connections between the kick
Sadiq bandleader and the Saturnalia of
Cecil Taylor and George Clinton the
summer Oz story is the mothership of
inventors like DJ Spooky and Coco su and
it's irrepressibly inspiring to look to
Saturn as the source of the queer
erotics of Grace Jones and Janelle Monae
and Tessa Thompson
well it's instructive to draw on a
genealogy of black radical aesthetics
incorporating Afrika Bambaataa and
afropunk my outlook on black sound and
its attendant technologies refers to the
work of Alex Haley a and Katherine
McKittrick - and through those
enunciations of black life that
represent the debasement of our
creativity as well as its ascendancy but
this course of phonography that Haley a
outlines reminds me and the kid Rick in
this case that black cultural politics
encompasses kanye west as well as Kumasi
washington it's problematic as [ __ ] i
worry that when we forget that in order
to elevate black genius to the ancestral
plane we remain preoccupied with the tip
of the iceberg and we miss the chance to
commemorate what McKittrick and Mihaly a
regard as vernacular photography's when
they cite inventions like the tr-808
drum machine in the title of their
articles 808s and heartbreak from which
this quote comes naming one of West's
albums and hit single by the artbeat
group black their writing of phonography
that dissenters the device itself in
order to situate the felt knowledge
evoked by the sensations associated with
it
these situations include pleasure but
also the heartbreaking violations
enacted by putative black geniuses in
their progeny like Afrika Bambaataa
Marvin Gaye and Robert Kelley when we
locate their significance and technical
mastery as well as emulation vernacular
uptake derivative works and reception
photography's then encompass the trauma
its oppression and its repetition
a reparative orientation of cultural
practices born out of trauma affords all
of those who take part of working
through them the chance to realize
potentialities those events seem to
foreclose and silenced my goal is to
reconstruct a photography of science
fiction radio drama in a way that
affords black feelings the same
complexity that we bring to our
relationship with rhythm and blues sound
is an absence a haunting this is its
nature sound is absence beguiling out of
sight out of reach what made the sound
who is there
sound is void fear and Wonder
David toups inquest into the inaudible
vibrations of literature is booked
sinister residents conjures an
alternative history of listening in
texts presumed to be silent
fundamentally he asks what is the
absence of sound the absence of
characteristic of what you could call
the new sound studies soon stir
resonance takes note of the fearful
symmetry that they earn and is called
resonance and reason the conjunction of
these terms in Ireland's work aims to
reconcile sympathetic vibration with the
unmoved dispassionate solidity of the
rational reviewer Pearlman retraces a
history of the ear as a site of
discernment that's equal in
sophistication to that of the learning I
when the ear resonates with external
stimuli argues it doesn't collapse the
distinction between the individual
subject and the world but it helps to
rationalize by representing the interior
of the self as the place where knowledge
becomes meaningful the tip of the
iceberg or its underside it's the part
that's not only invisible but the place
that the sound it makes comes from the
attitude of silence as a metaphor for
the violin excisions of colonial
rationality can the subaltern speak can
the hegemonic ear hearing thing has made
it sensible to locate resistance in
black sound however more recent
interventions in sound studies and
afrofuturism pursue what Kevin clay she
is called the sovereignty of quiet a
cultural politics that deliberately
attenuates loudness in order to
comprehend the interior day of black
beating more and more artists are
working a little bit softer now from so
long as some fun able to spy a to the
nairobi bass nests collective their
still images from their Wizards over
there they beckon us to listen for
enunciations of blackness and being that
do not cry out for a recognition after
all sometimes the most interesting
things black people do elude
identification when the racial
dimensions of meaning are turned inward
instead of outward facing when a
wordless look is what secures the act of
knowing the
silent companions that's when the
cultural modality I call black form
emerges as something other than
resistance the objective of my inquiry
into black cultural practices that don't
quite pierce the veil is not the
disavowal of resistance but affirmation
that are living and dying matter
despite the pall of accidental violence
the things we do are meaningful even if
their meaning is occluded in the words
of Christina sharp at stake is not
recognizing anti blackness as total
planet at stake too is not recognizing
an insistent black visual sonic
resistance to that imposition of
non-being by appraising black
participation in the whiteness of
science fiction and other endeavors that
do not announce themselves she became an
autonomous political framework organized
by race I hope to moon or memorialize
though going on being in black life what
we do every day what sharp refers to as
black being in wake when we're compelled
to ask what made the sound who is there
we're also invoking the questions posed
by my late mentor plus a Esteban Munoz
in his work cruising utopia but then and
there are queer Futurity in pursuit of
the Liberatore potential of transient
moments moments that pass that we may
never touch again munos consigned the
sublime and aleatory force of queerness
to conditions of possibility that are no
longer conscious and not yet here what
made the sound who is they
these holding spaces bygone eras idle
resonators and impossible desires are
silent for now maybe they're not empty
vestibules but chambers full of break
bated breath as hortense pillars writes
unvoiced awaiting their verb the inquiry
into untapped depths of the sonic
imagination and african-american
literature that Carter Malthus
undertakes so incisively an imagined
sound which amount of debate recognizes
at work in twenty Morrison's practice of
reading as listening bear witness to the
vibrancy of the black
tastic but I'm equally intrigued by the
heat still dissipating from the receiver
after the broadcast is ended and thus
Ashura between words that crackles with
potential energy in the sense
articulated by Jennifer Stoker I want to
break down the experimental traditional
binary to explore how what she calls the
sonic color lines disciplining of the
senses disrupts notions of universal
listening and therefore interested in
avant-garde as well as popular
Annunciations of black Futurity the
literary landmarks in the next phase of
my research don't quite represent the
mainstream of black studies
yeah because we're still beholden to a
vision of afrofuturism that is better
equipped to recognize our our claim to
authorship funk jazz and hip hop than
performance and adaptation black
participation in the tradition of
science fiction radio drama has yet to
be thoroughly articulated with a
soundscape of modernity the works that
will make up audio futurism exist then
in a state of decline to cite Brent
Edwards their stars awaiting their
constellation they consist of from 1967
the New York mind's eye theater
adaptation of the star Pitt novella by
Samuel Delaney that we talk about at
length at the end of the presentation
Delaney himself voiced the first person
narrator in the leading role and the
same studio produced a different radio
play with an original score by Sun rock
from 1979 the BBC radio production of
the coming space opera Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy which appeared as a
classic novel the following year in 2005
African American rapper and actor mos
def co-starred in the film adaptation as
the protagonists alien confidant Ford
Prefect
and is being brought back to radio later
this year probably while we speak on the
easy review now from 2002 an audio
adaptation of Octavia Butler's 1979 neo
slave narrative kindred starring
acclaimed african-american actor alfre
woodard pictured here from her role in
Star Trek covers contact this production
was part of the
cable television Syfy channel's
short-lived experiment in the internet
radio first performed in 2014 Jace
Clayton experimental sound artist who
performs as DJ rupture created the
Julius Eastman Memorial dinner an
interpretation of provocative works by
the black day experimental composer who
passed away in 1990 strung together by
speculative radio drama set in the near
future and finally from 2016 black
British playwright Patricia Cooper's
adaptation for BBC Radio of Toni
Morrison's haunting novel beloved the
prototypical text within the scope of
this inquiry is the inimitable broadcast
of the War of the Worlds on America in
1938 the most notable moment for me
occurs when the radio goes silent
following the debut of the martian
heat-ray
so a couple of things are going on one
is there a sound effect has to be
invented to make room for a certain kind
of silence and that silence has to be
interrupted has to be replaced has to do
some being because the non-being that
the listeners hear is very dangerous
unprecedented unknowable heretofore
silent um another thing that's going on
is the imagery while silence seems like
an appropriate image or absence I don't
know the length this seems appropriate
roundings that a finger will be the
right illustration for a moment like
that in the French edition of the War of
the Worlds published in 1906 in a French
edition the Edition utilized drawings
like these by a Brazilian artist named
Gendry album Correa who was from Belgium
I think originally but in his
illustrations which have a lot of sort
of a partner vowel imagery of the
packaging of the Edition looks very r0
on the outside this is a scene that
doesn't take place anywhere in the text
the caption for it on the website where
I found it
from the British library's holdings of
this object the caption for it on the
website was Martian gets the girl but of
course if you read the War of the Worlds
or if you've listened to it you know
that Martians don't want to get the girl
Martians can't even survive under the
Earth's atmospheric pressure and gravity
actually most of what makes Martian so
menacing is how strange and different
their physiology is you could even look
at Martians and say oh well they
obviously they have so many things but
one of the things they don't seem to
have is sex sex is not something that
you can tell the Martians have by
looking at them or listening to them you
can tell instead about a whole lot of
other things they have but as far as
whether they have sex your knowledge of
that is totally silent so its absence
from the recording its absence from the
text that's enunciated in this familiar
form I think is really offset by this
depiction that is right on point but
doesn't occur anywhere in the text and
it's kind of unbossed it brings up a lot
of things that that we can hear but
whatever we're hearing it's an echo of
something else not the text anyway the
the alien menace in the world world's
only hoodwinked a fraction of the
audience and its impact has been cited
as a precedent for other fiction about
the planet Mars rather than as a
touchstone for twentieth-century
treatments of race capitalist
exploitation fear of racial
contamination and degeneration and
colonialism on earth but for audio
futurism the War of the Worlds is the
ideal vanishing point when a livable
future for black cultural production can
trace the blood in its veins to the
beating red heart of the whiteness of
science fiction that's when this
tradition will belong to us the first
stop on my itinerary after the War of
the Worlds is the work
by daniel landau with Rhonda Haines
Walter Harris Jerry met Joan Tanner and
Phoebe ray the narration is by the
author the music for the star pit is
composed and performed by Susan Schwarz
the technical direction is by ed Woodard
and David wrapkin production assistant
to Neal Conan the Stargate first
appeared in worlds of tomorrow published
by the galaxy publishing corporation I
came across an essay by the author
while I was revising the manuscript for
a speculative blackness and I didn't
know what to do with it until years
later in his essay notes on the star pit
Delaney recounts the solicitation
adaptation casting recording editing and
broadcast of the radio play based on his
novella which was published in the
February 1967 world tomorrow
I followed the leads from his essay to
the Pacifica Radio archives online where
much to my delight the Public Radio
Institution disseminates the product of
a 2013 Grammy Foundation grant to
preserve the recordings produced from
1966 to 1969 by what was then the 99.5
radio theatre led by Bay Searles the
director of WV a is New York's WBAI New
York's drum and literature department
the Pacifica Radio archives in the
internet archive at archive.org now
hosts digitized versions of the magnetic
tape recordings from WAIS
archives including the star pit and the
other radio plays which the project
website reports ranked among among their
their most popular productions this
archive of dozens of works representing
the writings of many authors and
multiple genres and featuring an array
of actors and musicians living in New
York in the late 1960s obviously elicits
a wide range of interests for scholars
of literary literary adaptation
performance media history and sound
sights for my purposes today it provides
the basis for a substantive new
contribution to scholarship on the
intersection of race and
insufficient studies the star pit begins
with an announcers voice orienting
listeners to the title and provenance of
the material about to broadcast the
announcers voice delineates fact from
fiction but this isn't the last time
we'll hear from him as the story unfolds
the next sound here is non-diegetic it's
a flute / - herb iesous Schweers
played on an instrument made quote of
industrial housing with an inch and a
half or arbitrarily cut in an
arbitrarily cut in finger holes
according to the author
[Music]
[Music]
the first voice we will hear the
narrative is Delaney as the protagonist
and first person narrator whose aim is
vibe and the first thing with which he
populates the narrative is an object
containing non-human life as the flute
overture trails off in the background
the first word spoken in the star pit
literally frame a world within a world
the self-contained biosphere of an ant
colony this motif recapitulates itself
several times over within the story as
eco spheres now as large as a playground
jungle-gym now wearable behind a
magnifying glass on a dangling pendant
now the size of galaxies become figures
for the limits of life itself
the ants of vines childhood the size of
the earth is unfathomable but he lets us
know that much greater mysteries
revealed in the time he lives in make
our clone planet seemed like the
provincial Europe whose antique maps
used to read here be dragons before the
colonial era a flashback set apart from
vines adulthood travails by another
flute interlude reminds us about his
origins at the beginning of sage
[Music]
I was named for a ridiculous class I
thought then we'd spent putting together
a model killer intergalactic crime
throughout those dozens of helical
inserts and super inertia organics
sensitives I've been silently cursing my
teacher thinking about like everybody
else in the class so what if we can fly
these Gelardi from one galaxy not the
psychically physiologic shells hanging
around this cluster of the universe back
in the dormitory I was lying on my bed
straightening graphite lubricant for my
nails with the end of verse five the
rule and half meeting in a folded back
copy of the young mechanic when I saw
the article in the dick shirt through
some freakish accident two people have
been discovered who didn't crack up the
twenty thousand light-years off the
Galactic rim who didn't die at 25,000
I used the indefinite article a
space-age because there are now several
shifts in the state of human planetary
consciousness between the time of
Delaney's writing and the time about
which he writes in the future when he
wrote the star pit the Apollo missions
were bringing Americans to the moon and
within a generation new rockets and the
reusable Space Shuttle would make
international racially integrated
cross-gender collaboration in space a
viable career for scientists and
humanists alike I write about the social
significance of this moment envisioned
in popular media in Chapter two of
speculative blackness space race woman
on actor and astronaut recruiter
Nichelle Nichols vine grows up at the
tipping point between interstellar
travel an intergalactic exploration when
a new category of human beings is
leaving the rest of us behind advancing
beyond what we once thought was the
final frontier he addresses the reader
from the other side of that historic
watershed when earth and our Moon are a
homely old
to the vast majority of human beings who
live in diaspora he lets us know that at
the time of his speaking there will have
been a break within genres of the human
that makes it possible for some of us to
venture 20 thousand light years past the
Galactic rim beyond the final boundaries
of the age reason to a place that few
have seen many have heard about but very
few can come back from the voice of the
announcer returns to the broadcast to
explain why the few individuals capable
of movement between galaxies are so
exceptional from the cold planet surface
they looked solid as hell both of them
then there were more articles more
pictures and the economic journals the
sociology student letters the legal
bulletins as various fields began
acknowledging the impact that the golden
and the sudden birth and intergalactic
crane were having on the head of some
Commission send it up with a statement
though interstellar travel has been with
us for three centuries intergalactic
trade has been
ability not because of mechanical
limitations but rather because of
barriers that till now we have not even
been able to define some psychic shock
causes insanity in any human or for that
matter any intelligent species or
perceptual machine or computer that goes
more than twenty thousand light-years
from the Galactic rim then complete
physiological death as well as recording
breakdown in computers that might
replace human crews complex explanations
have been offered not completely
satisfactory but the base of the problem
seems to be this as the nature of space
and time are relative to the
concentration of matter in a given area
of the continuum the nature of reality
itself operates by the same or similar
laws the average mass of all the stars
in our galaxy controls the reality of
our micro sector of the universe but as
a ship leaves the Galactic rim reality
breaks down and causes insanity and
eventual death for any crew even though
certain mechanical laws no novel appear
to remain for reasons we don't
understand relatively constant say for a
few barbaric experiments done with
psychedelics of the Dhamma spatial
travel we have not even developed a
vocabulary that can deal with reality
apart from its measurable physical
expression yet just when we have to face
the black limit of intergalactic space
bright resources glittered within some
few of us whose tense of reality has
been shattered by infantile childhood or
prenatal trauma whose physiological and
psychological orientation makes life an
hour
society painful or impossible the
announcers voice re-enters the narrative
as an intertext ostensibly originating
in some incredible news source from
vines mutant and it jars the reader out
of the credulous disposition required to
treat science fiction's like
interstellar travel as if they were
science fact for the purpose of
appreciating new discoveries and
inventions posited within the story
world in his treatment of the language
of science fiction the dual hinged jaw
Delaney argues that writing in the genre
relies on a particular variety of
subjectivity such that we are able to
read phrases like he turned on his left
side
her world exploded in science fiction as
if they literally referred to an
electrical man separate power switches
for each half of his body and a female
inhabitant of a doomed planet
respectively in this context because it
recalls the listeners orientation to the
pre narrative content of the broadcast
the interpolation of the announcers
voice in parts of reality effect to his
words by forgoing the musical transition
that sets fiction apart from fact and
texturing the voice with a cop or
congestion this recurrence of an
authoritative voice linking vines memory
with our own smuggles in a rationale for
the limits of space exploration among
ordinary humans that is they succumb to
space madness when they travel too great
a distance from the familiar accretions
of matter that make up our galaxy it
also explains the Liberty enjoyed by the
unlikely errands of the new space age
their state of mind is already out of
sync with those of us grounded in the
perceptual behavioral norms of our
fellow rational creatures this reality
effect doesn't have to fool the listener
into believing the facts transmitted
through the announcers microphone are as
real as the nightly news as they
supposedly did in 1938 with the
broadcast of the War of the Worlds
instead its task is to perform what the
word the world's demonstrably achieves
for contemporary and original
is alike to make a distinction within
the text between highly subjective
character driven considerations and
those that are instrumental to the
internal consistency of the story the
same voice that let us know the star pit
was published in worlds of tomorrow now
lets us know that certain people can
overcome the apparent contradiction
between sanity and the aspirations of
intergalactic travel few of us whose
reality has been shattered by infantile
drama whose physiological and
psychological orientation makes life in
our society painful or impossible here
on the verge of the breakthrough within
Delaney's story world that Telegraph's
the social symbolism of the star bed is
where I part ways with the meaning most
readily assigned to its fictitious
renditions of identity and the best
interpretation of it out there in black
and brown planets a critical anthology
edited by the great Isaiah lavendar
Jerry Kahneman writes that the star pit
represents Delaney's confrontation with
the limits of racial identification he
contends that there are no such limits
the logic of racial difference extends
indefinitely into the identity of the
privileged and disadvantaged - like
subordinating the unmarked status of
whiteness to the quote authority of
racialized subjectivity after all since
whiteness is designed through the
exclusion of the racial other the
discourse of the other is the only site
from which it can be seen from outside
itself as something like a discrete
objectified form Canavan arrives at this
adept interpretation by reading the
figure for those improbable
psychologically traumatized humans who
can survive the voyage beyond the edge
of our galaxy and delay the story as a
deconstructed representation of
whiteness under a new mode of production
made possible by intergalactic travel
they alone possess the unique agency
necessary to advance human prerogative
on a more than human scale according to
this reading the people of Earth and all
but a few of our distant descendants are
all the colonized subject
vast intergalactic society where
precious leaked moves about freely
engaging in trade practicing
cosmopolitanism amongst themselves and
subordinating solar systems like our own
to their priorities along the way the
term that Delaney uses to assign
exceptional status to the site's master
races golden it's an adjective made an
app and it reads the value of the status
it distracts even though it goes on to
argue that Delaney deconstructs the
simple allegory for racial dominance
inscribed in the identification of space
travelers as a privileged elite I'm
skeptical about kenneth ins reading of
what golden means in racial terms and
therefore skeptical about what it means
to read it in racial terms the author's
enunciation of what sets them apart from
the majority of humans both in print and
especially in the version stage for the
radio play positions golden as the
embodiment of a concrete multifarious
form of marginality in the star hit
golden make up in a tiny improbable
minority of that otherwise predictable
fraction with an all gendered and
racialized populations whose state of
mind you will recall makes life in our
society painful or impossible I've
lighted the word interstellar from the
preceding phrase deliberately in order
to reiterate the ellipsis that describes
the star fair in class in the future in
the printed text the presence of the
word interstellar our interstellar
society masks the true and unspeakable
difference between the future society
delaney depicts here in our present
world the space race is already afoot at
the time of his writing chemical
propulsion is taking human beings to the
moon and back and nuclear fission powers
the dreams and nightmares of the Cold
War generation what sets the society in
which golden exists apart is not the
possibility of space travel but the
sight of land on its horizon the
denizens of this future society know
that they have a destination within
reach but it exceeds their grasp for the
most part golden the outcasts from this
society which is much like a room belong
to that space for the cast out the no
place or you take care to which we
relegate anomalies of the no longer
conscious and not yet here life is
already painful or impossible for the
class of non persons to whom golden
belong indeed there only discernible as
a distinct minority to the extent that
within their ranks a nonzero probability
of survival between the Galactic barrier
curves non person may be a harsh
characterization or let me explain when
the announcer from binds youth uses the
word golden he's modifying a word we
never here
the crossing and return the name golden
stuck his voice is preempted by Vimes
uncertainty in the text the first person
narrator wonders whether there was
static for the gentleman coughs he
remembers not hearing what he said he
doesn't remember what he heard instead
in the broadcast Delaney and his
interlocutors conspired to preserve this
mystery the announcer is already a bit
congested when he begins reporting the
discovery of golden foreshadowing the
interruption now a signal degradation
preempts the recovery of the speaker's
intentions as well in the time of the
audience the demonym that golden
modifies is an irretrievable secret the
text offers no clues
instead we're left with the problem of
how to reckon with the epithet as a
phenomenon that simultaneously a noise
and a silence but definitely not a word
the plot of the star pit revolves in
part around one of them's companions
trying to steal the trappings of golden
status so that he can steal away on an
intergalactic spaceship because he's not
really golden he is just as likely to
succumb to space madness as the tiny
organisms in an eco sphere are to
suffocate when they're removed from the
delicate equilibrium of their glass
enclosure nonetheless this young man
envies golden for their seemingly
endless mobility they are infuriatingly
oblivious to the consequences of their
privilege and an entire interstellar
society subscribes to norms that
guarantee them maximum freedom of
movement through space from Bynes point
of view it's hard not to sympathize with
the consensus voiced by the narrator and
his young friend that golden are
alternately mean and stupid the first
confrontation between mime and a
character who is golden folds the tenor
of the metaphorical whiteness of being
golden back into the vehicle and employs
in the story when vine narrowly avoids
crashing into another spacecraft piloted
by someone who happens to be golden we
begin to understand why they attract
such an odd combination of desire and
resent
and why we might at least initially take
whiteness as the point of departure for
what they represent the golden our
protagonist almost crashes into is Fino
typically black
this leads Kanna been to his
deconstructive reading of what they be
jerked around the status quo from the
Cuba I slammed on the video into common
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as figures for the reification of a
privilege that depends constitutively on
its difference from its comparatively
disadvantaged counterpart sure golden
are reportedly what
yet this figuration takes on a form of
embodiment that is within the story
literally identical with racial
blackness for some readers this poses a
paradox how can a propose of Lee black
character attain all of the trappings of
whiteness if that's what being golden
means without passing that is being the
negation of blackness not being black if
the new interstellar society of the star
pit allocates privilege according to the
logic that makes racial distinctions
meaningful how could a member of any
racially subordinated group ascend to
the pinnacle of human activity on a more
than planetary scale one interpretation
is that this futures get another
instance of science fiction refuting the
inadequate and self-contradictory social
construct of race
complicated as that sounds I don't know
if things are that simple learning that
golden can be black only intensifies my
attention to what goes unsaid in the
language community of the future but
golden is a marked category while
whiteness is not instructs the reader a
listener to pay attention to the way
that people talk about the constituents
of this victim category when they might
not otherwise when buying almost crashes
into the pilot whose golden he stammers
a great big stupid stupid words fail
moments later in the exchange with his
startled co-pilot vine tries to explain
the tunnel by calling out the golden so
his Confederate knows who's at fault but
he can't even come up with a suitable
obscenity and his copilot is incredulous
anyway now Delaney has written reams
about obscenity often in profane
vernacular but the star pate is written
in such a way that something other than
propriety obfuscates the content of
these statements either golden is
profane enough on its own and that
doesn't seem likely or there's nothing
more to be said because one of the
powers golden annexes to itself through
the peculiar circumstance of its coinage
is the occlusion of an inherently
negative meaning the golden can't mean
anything profane in that way it is very
much like whiteness because there's
virtually no epithet for white that
constitutes an unspeakable racial slur
golden strangely makes that unspeakable
'ti legible the epigraph to Canada's
treatment of the star pit quotes Delaney
placing himself on society's margins to
frame the essay has an exploration of
social marginality he is black he is a
sexual minority and he has spent time in
a mental hospital
each of these testimonials and invests
the author with an affirmative quality
of what sally has leaders called moral
entitlement a standpoint from which his
experience of Fortson credibility
regarding the systems of power
structured by race sexuality and the
carceral ableism that characterizes the
diagnosis and treatment of psychological
health and modern society it's not that
I disagree with Canada's appraisal per
se and if he were here
I'm gonna write him a nice email but
then I'm interested in other dimensions
of the star pits tapestry of race and
genre for one the analysis in question
only deals with the print version of the
novella rather than it's at least
equally significant and arguably more
significant Radio adaptation the
commemoration of the broadcast a year
after year and its role in a
preservation project make it worthwhile
to revisit the after lives of the
meanings inscribed in the text in light
of their reiteration inaudible form
moreover in felicitous turn Katamon
juxtaposes the star kid with another
tech central to my interests far beyond
the stars an episode of the 1990s Star
Trek spin-off series
Deep Space 9 which is famously stars and
is directed by a black actor in the
leading role Avery Brooks the episode in
question recounts a speculative story
about the history of racial
discrimination and the lives of science
fiction writers that I discuss in detail
in one chapter of speculative blackness
great minds think alike basically what's
missing or at least understated in far
beyond the star pit is an acknowledgment
of how these works function as
touchstones for the study of literary
adaptation as a staging ground for the
cultural politics of race and genre
the dimension of the star pit that I
find most ripe for exploration echoes
the author's self defining gesture from
the Straits of Messina the author
Delaney's knowledge of society's margins
including his vulnerability to
incarceration due to race sexuality and
pathology as assigned to his mental
state are all interconnected within his
experience because he's the one living
this is not and I wholeheartedly agree
with other readers in this regard a
cause for interpreting Delaney's fiction
as a failed memoir instead it's a
reminder that human experiences of
social marginality privileged and
disadvantaged are multi-dimensional if
we regard the socially symbolic element
in the narrative of the star tip through
the prism of intersectionality I argue
we arrive at a more adequate
interpretation of what golden means in
relation to matters of race gender
genre and madness this is also germane
to reading the text
a composite of its audible and it's
silent print and satiation before we
have the opportunity to learn what
golden means and before we witness what
it is that makes life painful or
impossible in the interstellar Society
of the star pit we learned that buying
the protagonist's has lived in a quote
procreation group on a distant planet
with several husbands and wives
co-parenting the children they have
conceived in common is a good way to
colonize other planets with human
populations it's among these children
that he maintains an eco-lodge area a
grown-up version of the ant colony from
his childhood for lack of a better word
the silent partner to golden in the text
is queer it's never spoken but if we
could hear it queer would further
confound the intersecting
context-sensitive privilege in ISM
comparative disadvantages that accrue to
being golden in the story queer is an
adjective but it can constitute an alumn
when used in the katha Christic way that
golden simultaneously modifies and
occludes its object and what is queer
but a partial description of the
psychological and physiological
orientation that makes life painful or
impossible in our society yet
nonetheless enables a few of those
golden to make the crossing and return
the prospect that beckons at the
intersection of black and golden is
clear insofar as it implies a relation
between the two quantities that while it
might not be a relation of identity
means something that can't be said any
other way I'm listening for the
resonance that makes the word spelled
gol de in sound like what to some
readers sound like black like queer
because it represents the tip of the
iceberg that sounds like it refers to
something you know but it looks like
something else thank you
[Applause]
it totally fits it's part of the it's
part of the narrative that we already
use to kind of animate afrofuturism as a
black knowledge practice that repurposes
inventiveness and innovation and and
does that innovation thing in a way
that's different from say like canonical
modernism and that that narrative is is
part of it and I feel like a deepening
of our knowledge of what people who
create a techno and German Basin house
did with technology and why they did it
and what they created not just like it
sounds like creative machines they
created but photography's in the sense
of life spaces narratives that they
created are very much part of that
itinerary I also think that it um it's a
reminder to me to UM to look back at I'm
Trisha roses book black noise which does
not get enough love because she was
talking about you know black Rico
lawyers repurposing disused technical
materials like to kind of invent new
forms of cultural capital for themselves
you know in the black working class in
the Bronx like she was talking about
that at the time and it it hasn't quite
connected up with the similar histories
that we have for some other genres of
music but it's like it's right there
right there Tricia Rose
I
thank you
I was kind of wondering how ideas around
in figure into I might need a rumble
Native Americans and rock that I thought
was interesting but also your head
tensions around claiming things yeah so
I'm kind of curious about how yeah um
intersect is the word for it right
because because what intersectionality
actually means which you can look up in
like you can look it up you can
attribute it to the person who pointed
it Kimberly Crenshaw it's not a
disparaging stereotype about women who's
taller but like intersecting means that
people are simultaneously black and
indigenous and also sometimes indigenous
and not black and also sometimes some of
those other things while they are also
gendered and plastun national and on
national and like all those things there
is I think a value to investigating
where black and indigenous connections
take place in the histories of you know
black diasporic North American
identities and in cultures I think that
the ways that for instance language
learner the ways that black people come
into native nations as language learners
tells us something
how are different oral traditions and
cosmologies and like phenomenology x'
around the word in a spoken form how
they interact how the interface like
that's a fascinating site for
exploration that but maybe maybe deals
with a little bit of that like do we
need to ever raise the question of black
versus indigenous or can black versus
indigenous means something like a remix
right like this versus that can it mean
that I think that one of the things we
might get from say communities in which
black people become constituents become
part of Native Nations is thinking about
how language learning is part of that
process I think that they spoken and
silent role of slavery in treaties and
violations of treaties with Native
Nations are places where the relation of
nationality and Empire to black neces is
ceated or not enunciated right it's
silenced and those those circuits those
moments those interactions where
somebody has to talk to someone else
someone has to speak or make people or
make a situation or make a land speaker
or speak for it those moments I think
are good moments to take up those
questions of like is this a black and
indigenous situation what dimension of
this is lack and not indigenous and what
dimension of it is indigenous and not
black if it is like those can actually
coexist at certain moments in a way
that's not violating and I hope to to
see that
this is a fantastic talk thank you so
much for this I'm thinking about it I
feel like there's a little bit of a
irony and beautiful images from all the
stars that you're using so they're ill
astray ting the you know the gold
texture and so on and so forth and
you're talking about the golden as you
know you're rereading it as figuring for
queer and yet you know people have been
talking about the straight washing or
the erasure of the queer suppliants from
black panther and you know it's most
explicitly articulated by Roxane gay is
rolled up or Conda side series which has
very explicit multiple same-sex lesbian
relationships between door and logic but
then and and they're also doing this
amazing work of sort of challenging
patriarchy inside in science or Kannada
that gets read that as not a utopia but
yes there are still there are things
that are amazing about this vision about
furniture for futurism and mass spaces
never been colonized and yet they're
still hetero patriarchy and sexual
slavery so I'm wondering if you could
that and I don't know if it's an erasure
but I'm wondering how you think about
that is it was it there's just too much
or a mass-market cultural tax why did
that happen
alright it's not too much right because
it's a it's kind of the dilemma that I
have with like using fictionalized in
terms of difference surrogates for
rather than like Windows on two or
elaborations on the differences that we
experience and know um the problem I
have with that often is that like there
is no such thing it's too much right so
you can't be like oh we're all cool now
because we've gotta fight the board
right or like nah we're all we're cool
now because the Martians are here and
like we are clearly not cool when the
Martians come you're like hold up we're
still racist we can't do this yet right
like like they just can't like what
Conda might have a plan for the Martians
willing everything
what the existing Nations and radio
frequencies um in that moment um my
uptake of that visual is deliberate
because I like you know it's like a
residence and that's so exciting and fun
it's it's it's attention-grabbing and
rhetorically effective from a place of
like producing aesthetic pleasure um to
the extent that it pulls these
narratives together from different
moments and asks about like a shared
tradition that's just a a total novel
practice that they have to be part of
right um I think that whatever is like
part of like what I arrive at in reading
a figure like golden as something like
queer is in part especially because it's
not said and because um reading what
golden comes to mean in this fictional
context and the society it imagines
requires are working through of what
clearness means by a variety of other
names it's really fascinating to me that
here can be unspoken right can be spoken
right as the counterpart to what is
spoken there right queer can be spoken
now whereas in the been in there or the
story it's not spoken that's that's a
fascinating a useful thing about having
critical terminology being it'll speak
of things in multiple times in places
and I feel like that work which I call
katha Christic because I think it's like
its kind of its kind of retrograde it's
not cool but there was like a weird
moment where I think like Vivian namaste
and some other
queer critics or some other critics some
other feminist critics who authored
seminal text in queer theory
we're like struggling a little bit with
the kind of inflation phase of queer
theory right where it accelerated faster
than the speed of light and then like
now we have mass in the universe um that
that moment to me and thinking through
how queer can be and can like Sarah Mann
says not have a relation of externality
to what it describes it's fascinating
it's like golden right in that you you
don't know you don't need to know you
can't know the the term it modifies in
an ideal state because there is no
discrete ideal State
for it to modify because all it modifies
is something already spoken for somebody
who is golden and also black somebody
who is golden and also diagnosed with
schizophrenia somebody who was golden
and probably in the world of Delaney's
story susceptible to being diagnosed
with with a variety of well susceptible
to being diagnosed with a
psychopathology because of the relation
between their sexuality their gender
expression than their and their gender
identity right like in that world life
is painful or impossible psychologically
and so the world of Delaney's story is
one in which mmm we can apply the term
golden to such a person otherwise that
person is not a discrete category a
person they're non person right there's
only the category only coalescence
insofar as you can identify the
subsection of it among whom golden might
exist all that stuff say um I feel like
in the way that golden names instead of
it names instead of something that could
be named otherwise and queer does that I
feel like what you see in especially
this variety of popular cultural black
futurist stuff especially this popular
cultural variety of it ISM is sometimes
a silence and it's sometimes
inarticulate silence and sometimes an
inarticulate silence what I think can be
articulate about it is like an
inarticulate science it's like well I
don't want to write is editing out is
this decision or that is you know a
discrete naming and doing on screen
before the camera or not write those
loose and inarticulate silence it's that
you can do in those ways um but what
might be articulate is on the argument I
take up in an article about black
panther about the comics that will come
out later this year um is kind of about
this moment about like what do we do now
everybody's talking about this what is
the vocabulary we used to talk about it
and when I say is basically like some of
the things that are spoken for in terms
of the desiring practices that are
legible and and and like argued for
right some of those positions on what
identity and desiring mean and do in a
narrative like this are spoken for by
the term black that doesn't mean they
can't be spoken forward by the term
queer but it means that saying they can
be spoken for about the term black is
not a refusal to answer what the place
of desire is and then it is an answer to
those questions and I feel like that's a
thing because like because the kind of
the performance that that Danai gurira
does in that film and like the
performance that Tessa Thompson did in
thor ragnarok have they have these
qualities of like inarticulate silence
where they're just like hmm don't do
that right don't signify that but they
also have that quality that everything
has which is like you don't just not
signify anything even if you don't
signify the
in particular you signify something and
also not something and whatever that is
one of the things it is is an answer to
[Music]
to nation and gender and desire that
needs to be understood as as in the
lexicon of blackness and I feel like
it's not that black people are not queer
it's that black people are not not being
black when they're being queer so like
when black people are being queer
they're also being black and so some of
the things that we look for won't show
up the way that we expect them like you
cannot you can't populate the the
queerness of whatever the afro in the
afro Futurity of the queer Futurity of
this narrative is you can't populate it
with people who are not black and i feel
like there is something there rather
than something rather than only
something that's not there right so like
yeah to an extent okay there is an
absence of black lesbians as such there
is an erasure of black lesbian as such
very good
smart writers like Joe Gomez and Roxane
gay have taken that question in
informative places that allow us to
learn from it rather than see it as like
it then only experiences as the
epistemic violence that it is that no
there's no learning there's nothing to
know there's nothing to see here
right we didn't even cut it out we
didn't even ask that we got a director
who wouldn't have it right it's not just
that
so yeah I'm like I'm passionate about it
because I'm like blackness is it just
were so desire and then I'm also like
mmm you can erase in silence some things
that that sometimes don't nests that
sometimes articulate you with with
something other than a total opposition
co-optation
ever questioned I guess basically about
the kind of geography of the project
number of the I think the like radio
plays you mentioned were BBC adaptation
humans and afrofuturism is such a
capacious I think kind of body of works
but there's been like such a I kind of
push back now on the kind of
geographically I'd like how much a
future is acro futurism versus so I'm
just curious about how you're thinking
the geography of that why the kind of
BBC you know when I think kind of like
British so now I'm just kind of curious
about that the geographers how you're
thinking afrofuturism as a kind of
geographic practice um yeah yeah I think
that's like my strategic and glows and
prism right which is which is both a
recognition that black British but also
that that our our relationship to each
other is a circuit of meaning that's
generative there and also like an effort
to not try to do too much is a part of
that work so what I want to achieve by
by maintaining that deliberate US and
British relay is is to to get some
things out of it right that it has to to
give us to show us and also to to do the
the thing that I hope it does is kind of
restore some of the geography right to
kind of speak to you okay why have these
it's in the Anglophone world what does
that phone mean right like who is it who
is in the language community of English
speakers and readers how are these
traditions from you know from from like
a George Schuyler black weird satirical
not quite afrofuturism to to you know a
new new way
British 1960s science fiction how are
those moments like varieties of
Anglophone cultural practice in which
blackness is integral I'm interested in
that I'm also interested in like the
varieties of Lucifer and hispanophone
cultural practice and francophone
cultural practice that are informative
and in the other diasporic sites that
have like a whole different set of
questions embedded in them politically
and geographically but I also know I'm
not that good at and other people are
much better at engaging with them so I'm
like very yeah I feel motivated to stay
in my lane but I'm also like it's a it's
an HOV Lane it's like a it's like I'm
not alone in it right which is why I'm
like there's no such thing as a purely
as a national framing that contains
right there is only a national frame
that articulates with other national and
national rights so I'm like oh okay
so this one will be like this so yeah
that's a I feel like there's something
to the US and British circuit there and
the Tiffani barber is doing phenomenal
excellent work on black audio film
collecting alessandro Rango sometimes in
collaboration with with Tiffany Barber
and Amy Elias and some of these folks
some are also reanimating conversations
around I
Julian's work and like I am really
excited and and you'll affirmed by that
because it's like oh it's not that it's
not that black Americans and black
British stuff can continue to be hot but
it's also um you know that that there is
good company to do
as part of the strategy
mm-hmm
in
um yeah yeah there's a there's are like
a there's a kind of I think a
short-circuiting and uh naturalizing
that can happen right with the
presumption that blackness will be loud
they will agitate it will resist and and
I think most people who want to consider
you know lack knowledge production in
sound as a site of knowledge production
are really invested in saying like well
sure it resists domination but it also
involves you know we resist so that we
can do other things you know so that we
can go on being and you can
simultaneously know about learn about
the going on being and learn about like
remote in talks about like the
saturation that makes that is the sound
right you can you can be there and there
can be a totality to it and you can be
identical with it right but you can also
have relations to it that are not
relations of identity and I think that's
that's interesting right so that so the
thing that echoes or reiterates a moment
or or turns it down or like you know
mixes it in otherwise right those ways
of those ways of doing you know black
cultural work and doing any cultural
work right that that give sound these
different roles allow you to you know
create sound scapes that have different
relations to each other right so that so
that you have a place that you would
like to be right a place that is not yet
here but utopian resin and one of the
things you do by gesturing toward it or
moving toward it is that you you negate
the here and now but you don't just to
get here now you negate it for a second
right you negate it for song you get it
for a night and I'm like that's that's
interesting that's fun that's useful
because it does hopefully move into
inhabiting that
here and what is um you know what it is
acoustically yeah as a kind of space
right that you can inhabit that because
it is a space because it has a geography
because it has a time has a sound is
part of what makes it what it is um
that's that's why I'm interested in like
repurposing of the technologies to make
different kinds of music right the
repurposing relays as music and and
they're recombining of music in order to
produce noise like that all sounds like
noise to me because I'm you know
something right it makes me a bad critic
right I'm aesthetically not smart enough
to understand why it's music but I know
that somebody is right about it and I'm
not so I'm like okay what are you doing
that I am NOT doing I don't have a
relation of identity to you you are
creating and inhabiting a space who's
whose imaginary architecture makes this
sound articulates it with desire and all
this stuff that's Philly and I'm like
that's a fascinating set of things to do
at the least we can understand people's
motivations for that even if they're on
an agenda that's not ours right so to me
the the what resistance means situation
is like yes not all the sounds people
make our resistance yes being is not
only resistance but also um you can you
know you can be a member of a coalition
and a member of a totality and a member
of a multi-faceted constituency or of an
intergenerational succession that that
has moments that are
resistance and has moments that are not
and so one of the things you can learn
from studying the ones that are not is
to learn how we differentiate them and
why it matters and how to get from one
to the other so yeah I'm interested in
music that does not do much and does not
do well and this is part of my thing
about Black Panther too is like I'm
interested in texts that fail at certain
things but like I'm you know it's it
just it's that heartbreak thing because
I'm like well yeah all anything is is
failing at doing something else you know
it's like you know blackness can't be
non-being it's oh no it's failing to be
white oh no I guess I'll just have to go
on being awesome like this is like it
it's fine or at least it should be
right and that horizon a possibility
that you want to attain as always not
here that's okay this is where we are
now and and I like treating like met
just like [ __ ] up cultural politics as
informative and informative
not because they achieve something we
should strive to achieve necessarily but
informative precisely in the way that we
can say like ooh that's really you know
the Masters of the tr-808 are the worst
let's instead look at you know people
who synthesized the sounds it makes or
people who sampled them and give us
better songs that don't make us feel
dead inside when we hear them like let's
do that instead so there are lots of
them yes there there are some things to
do with with failures to resist failures
to to be something that our that our our
acts of being something else
thank you
[Applause]